foreign
America
a vast cultural territory that spans
from Baja to Patagonia
covering 15 of the land on Earth
home to cultures is Rich and diverse as
the landscape
[Music]
our journey starts North in Mexico
a country of ancient empires and natural
bounty
[Music]
the first stop is the state of Baja
California Sur
the lower part of a peninsula that
splits the Pacific Ocean from the Gulf
of California
here we find the Loreto Bay National
Park an imposing site for its dramatic
Cliffs
[Music]
in This Magnificent landscape we can
find a wide variety of marine fauna
including the California sea lion
one of four species of sea lions in
Mexico
[Music]
these waters are also home to the
gracious bottlenose dolphin
[Music]
agile and smart citations are a truly
Global species as they can live in both
temperate and tropical waters
social mammals
so it is common to see them in groups
displaying their great ability to swim
and jump
the gulf known in Mexico as the sea of
Cortes was once described by
oceanographer Jacques Cousteau as the
world's Aquarium
[Music]
its beauty and importance appear to be
as clear as the waters found in the
archipelago Espiritu Santo
which is a natural protected area
declared a world heritage site by the
United Nations
[Music]
the archipelago has five Islands
the largest one Espiritu Santo
is 63 miles long
its geography is defined by Monumental
Cliffs made by layers of volcanic rock
[Music]
It is believed that the Spanish
conquistador Hernan Cortes named it the
island of pearls
due to its high population of molests
a different National Treasure is found
on the other side of the peninsula on
the shores of the Pacific Ocean the
viscaino biosphere Reserve and the
imposing salt mine of Guerrero negro
[Music]
this mine is the largest producer of
salt in the world
and is three times the size of the City
of Paris
[Music]
the 8.8 million tons of salt produced
here annually could meet the average
salt consumption in the U.S for almost
20 years
[Music]
further south at the tip of the
peninsula is Cabo San Lucas and its
stunning rock formations
thank you
the most emblematic site here is the
Stone Arch
sculpted for thousands of years
by winds and pounding waves
these beaches now attract tourists and
our secret Refuge to celebrities fleeing
Hollywood
[Music]
that they were once a danger for vessels
passing through
because they sheltered Pirates
the caves carved by the Sea particularly
in the Bay of Santa Maria were a perfect
Hideout for Buccaneers hoping to Ambush
Spanish galleons
on the opposite side of Mexico is the
Yucatan Peninsula where natural wonders
and the Maya civilization have shaped
each other for centuries
Lagoon
[Music]
the intense blue spot in the middle is a
steep Cenote that descends 269 feet
the Maya believed it was a passage
Between Two Worlds
[Music]
there are over seven thousand cenotes in
the Yucatan Peninsula
Wells that formed from millions of years
of rainfall
and the force of underground Rivers
they play a central role in the region
this is evident in the heart of the Maya
Empire the city of Chichen Itza
the name in Maya means mouth of the well
a reference to its sacred Cenote
[Music]
according to ancient Tales this well of
196 feet in diameter was used for human
sacrifices
including virgin women
who would someday come back to life
it is now called the Cenote of sacrifice
the remains of 42 human skeletons
and fragments of pre-hispanic ceramic
found here reveal that those sacrificed
actually died on land
and were then thrown to the well
the sacred Cenote of Chichen Itza is
aligned with the imposing pyramid of The
Feathered snake
which is also built on top of a water
well
this Majestic building is 196 feet wide
and 79 feet high
each side of the pyramid has 91 steps to
the top
when added together the steps on all
four sides and the top platform equal
365.
one for each day of the year
Specialists point to this as evidence
that the Maya calendar matches the
Gregorian calendar we use today
at its peak Chichen Itza had a surface
area of about 10 square miles and became
the most powerful Maya City in the
peninsula of the Yucatan
the population ranging between 50 and
000 people
if Chichen Itza is an emblem of the Maya
Empire nearly 250 miles away is an
emblem of the architecture and
urbanization of the Spanish Colonial
period
Campeche
United Nations UNESCO named Campeche a
world heritage site for the excellent
conservation of its buildings
because it was the Region's most
important port in the 17th century
Pirates were constantly attacking to
loot its riches
so the Spanish Crown built a military
defense system along the entire Bay
the hexagonal wall was built with eight
bastions and four doors
the forts of San Jose and San Miguel
were added later on both sides of the
city to reinforce its defenses
fending off Pirates was not the only
preoccupation of the Spanish Crown as
the number of churches reveals they were
also busy evangelizing
the Church of the San Roman neighborhood
was built in honor of the martyred Saint
Roman
it holds the so-called black Christ
which is the center of one of the most
important festivities in Campeche
the San Roman Fair
on the Eastern side of the Yucatan
Peninsula Mexico is contoi Island where
the ixla check coral reef becomes
visible
it is the starting point to the second
largest Barrier Reef in the world the
Mesoamerican Reef
which runs all the way to Belize
[Music]
the barrier often reaches the surface
this produces the peculiar phenomenon of
waves breaking in the middle of the sea
every year between May and October
the whale shark arrives to these Waters
[Music]
it is the largest fish in the world
and it comes here to feed and mate
[Music]
the whale shark is on the endangered
species list
the Yucatan Peninsula is home to around
1 100 specimens from an estimated 7 000
left in the world
moving further east on the Caribbean we
find the Dominican Republic
[Music]
Santo Domingo the capital was the first
city founded by the Spanish in the
American continent
and it still stands proudly facing the
sea
here the Spanish built a fort in 1502 to
defend themselves from Pirate attacks
just 10 years after Christopher Columbus
set foot here for the first time
[Music]
The Fortress was the first one built by
The Conquistadors
[Music]
in colonial times Spanish Damas or Dames
would wear their best gowns and walk
along this street
now called La Caya de las Damas
across the street from the Fortress is
the Cathedral of Santa Maria la Menor
known as the First Cathedral of the
Americas
its construction started in 1521 and was
completed 20 years later
[Music]
the cathedral is also the stage for a
big mystery
the fate of Christopher Columbus's
remains
the Genovese Navigator died in via the
lead Spain and his remains were brought
here
some believe that the remains were later
Taken to Havana and possibly returned to
saviti though the Dominican Republic and
Spain both claimed to have them
[Music]
the weather can be as hot as some of
these disputes but after Nightfall
the breeze offers a break for those
looking to dance merengue
[Music]
traditional music is played every Sunday
at the ruins of a monastery for
Dominicans and tourists alike
[Applause]
[Music]
the United Nations recognized Merengue
as oral and intangible Heritage of the
world
because it reflects the diverse origins
of Dominican culture
the Guida a large metal cylinder that is
played with a type of Comb is Taino the
drums are African and the accordion was
brought by the Spanish colonists
[Music]
23 miles from the city center
a coral reef helped shape the small Bay
of Boca Chica a natural pool of salt
water that is only 3.2 feet deep
the coral reef serves as a barrier to
the rough sea and makes this a calm
beach one that extends for almost a mile
[Music]
the water around the reef is crystalline
because it is permanently filtered by
natural underground currents
[Music]
the coral Flora along with mangroves and
seagrass attract a large variety of fish
and shellfish
this makes Boca Chica a suitable
ecosystem for sustainable fishing
[Music]
about an hour East by car a different
tradition is being preserved
in an unexpected Renaissance City that
bursts out of the Caribbean landscape
artos de chavon in La Romana
this replica of a 16th century
Mediterranean Village was conceived by
an American businessman and built in the
1970s
it has museums ateliers and even a Roman
Amphitheater that still holds musical
concerts and can seat up to 5 000 people
[Music]
meanwhile on the Northern side of the
island
Mother Nature has a Hidden Gem of its
own
the Samana peninsula
[Music]
the area grows the highest concentration
of coconut palm trees per square foot in
the world
for their Harvest a traditional method
is still used
with this stick and blade a single
person can go through 250 palm trees in
a day
[Music]
the coconut is part of the culture of
this peninsula inhabited by descendants
of Taino Spanish French and freed
African-American slaves
the Methodist Church of Santa Barbara de
Samana the capital of the province is
Testament to the African-American
presence in the region
[Music]
the small wooden construction is known
as La chucha a Spanish variation of the
English word church
it was built by freed African-American
slaves who were offered farming lands
here
[Music]
foreign
to the residents of Santa Barbara the
church is the only surviving structure
from a 1946 fire that destroyed Samana
[Music]
across the seminar Bay is Los heightises
National Park
and at the foot of one of its mountains
like a gift from the ground
is Laguna Cristal
which is not a lagoon but a Cenote
[Music]
thank you
the
656-foot Deep crater feeds off the
underground water from the mogotes
isolated Rock elevations that can reach
131 feet in height
[Music]
foreign
it is the birthplace of the barakote
a river that nourishes one of the main
water basins in the province
[Music]
mangroves grow along the banks of this
long river
and locals take advantage of the
wetlands to grow rice
one of the most suitable crops for the
region
[Music]
water is one of the key attractions in
the Dominican Republic
in the Samana Peninsula the waterfall
Sarto Limon creates a natural pool
thank you
[Music]
it was declared a natural monument in
1996 and is part of a protected area of
over six square miles
[Music]
half an hour away is the Hidden Paradise
of Las terenas
a small coastal town that was
essentially isolated until the 1970s
with no electricity or running water
[Music]
the town has 11 miles of Coastline
mostly beaches and the occasional
mangroves and Rocky areas
[Music]
this reef is directly related to the
coastal mangroves and the palm tree
Forest that go all the way to the shore
[Music]
further into the peninsula is Fronton
Beach
Cliffside turns into a huge marble
outcrop
fleets and aficionados alike
climb this rock that overlooks the Bay's
crystalline Waters
with coral reefs and tropical fish
[Music]
in the easternmost corner of Samana
is madama Beach
[Music]
in this rugged area
erosion from the sea created the Cliff
of LA ondonada
carving parts of the walls to form an
incredible Stone Bridge
these natural constructions stand the
test of time
but those made by humans did not have
the same luck
La Isabella was the first Spanish
settlement built in all the Americas
Columbus ordered the construction of
this Citadel where no building remains
but we can still see the foundations of
his house
The Fortress
the first church
and the graveyard
what still stands is a 500 year old tree
that could have seen Columbus himself
though the roots of Latin American
culture go back much further in time
moving back to Continental land in the
Pacific coast of South America is Peru a
nation tied to the Sea by
1860 miles of coastline
Peru is home to amazing fauna and is
also the Cradle of some of the most
developed pre-hispanic cultures in the
continent
Lima the only capital city in South
America that faces the sea
thank you
a modern city that blends contemporary
expressions with ancient cultures and
the legacy of the Spanish occupation
on land there are hundreds of colonial
monuments and sacred pre-columbian sites
at Sea the powerful waves attract
Surfers from all over the world
[Music]
13 and a half miles of cliffs separate
the city streets from the ocean
the slope inclines 40 degrees but at the
Miraflores District it is a dizzying 85
degrees
[Music]
The Cliffs of the Costa Verde or Green
Coast are a result of millions of years
of erosion from the ocean
Lima has a long history of earthquakes
[Music]
and tsunamis
many in Lima look to avert this Fate by
engaging in the multitudinous procession
of El Senor De Los Milagros
a tradition that started after a strong
earthquake in 1687.
the first Saturday of October the city
of Lima is covered in purple
over one million people participate in
the 20-hour long procession
paying tribute to the Lord of Miracles
a unique Peruvian image of Jesus Christ
[Music]
the official story links this Christ to
a 17th century painting by an angone
slave
[Music]
over six hours south by car from Lima
the desert holds wanders from ancient
worlds
in the region of Ika
bordering the Western Andes
we find the Nazca Lines a legacy of
pre-inka civilizations
an area of around 174 square miles
containing a system of more than 800
straight lines
300 geometrical figures and others of
animals plants and human-like drawings
that can only be seen from above
It is believed that the drawings were
carved in the sand between 200 BC and
500 A.D
[Music]
some researchers suggest that they were
used for astronomy and as a rain
calendar for agriculture
others think that they are
manifestations of a social and religious
nature
some even venture to say they were
Landing guides for extraterrestrial
vessels
[Music]
we can only confirm that this is a
system of figures that range between 164
and 980 feet in length and reveal great
engineering capabilities by those who
built them
Peru the heart of the Inca Empire
[Music]
a civilization that covered over 1 500
miles in the South American Andes
from the 12th to the 6th
[Music]
after the Spanish Conquest it became the
epicenter of Christian evangelization in
the Andean world
[Music]
20 churches
many of which were built on top of Inca
palaces and temples
the main one is the Basilica Cathedral
De Cusco in front of the plaza de armas
it took 132 years to build
using blocks of red granite extracted
from the Inca Fortress of success huaman
there's also the Church of San Cristobal
built on top of what was the front
square of korcampata Palace
the house of manko Kapak considered the
first Inca ruler
[Music]
Cusco abounds in colonial Arts
art but it's also the door to one of the
most important archaeological regions in
South America
[Music]
Peru's Indian Highland
also known as the sacred Valley
this region of Peru is where the Inca
developed their military power and
harvesting techniques
under two hours by car Northwest from
Cusco in the small town of oyentambo
at 9160 feet above sea level it offered
a vantage point for the Inca to
safeguard one of the largest food
producing areas in the Empire
foreign
the town's military purpose is evident
in its pink Granite monoliths and the
carved Stone Terraces
the ones leading to the Temple of the
sun were not used for agriculture but to
avoid erosion
in town time seems to have stopped
many of these buildings date back to
Inca times
so they may be the oldest houses still
in use in South America
[Music]
a railroad that starts in Cusco
passes through oyatay Tambo
and ends at the foothills of the
legendary Machu Picchu
[Music]
the final part of the route follows the
urubamba river as it descends to the
sacred Valley
here the vegetation becomes increasingly
jungle like
[Music]
then in the middle of this dense
wilderness
one of the Seven Wonders of the World
appears
[Music]
at an altitude of around 8 000 feet
almost 80 000 Acres of protected land
surround the archaeological site of
Machu Picchu
The Lost City
[Music]
built in the 15th century by the Inca
government of bachacutec
[Music]
it was the administrative political and
religious center of the empire
[Music]
so why build this incredible Citadel on
top of a seemingly inaccessible Mountain
[Music]
one of the strongest theories suggests
that the fault lines of no Machu Picchu
provided large fractured rocks that
could be used as construction material
[Music]
Ingenuity for using Nature's Bounty and
construction is still alive and well in
Peru
in Lake Titicaca there are around 80
hand woven Islands Housing close to 1
800 people
[Music]
using totora a type of tool this unique
group of islands was built by the uros
an ancient culture of water people as
they call themselves
oh
they escape from Inca Rule and took
refuge in Lake Titicaca the world's
highest navigable Lake
[Music]
to build the islands they collect the
roots of the todora as it grows during
the rainy season
and cut them into large blocks
[Music]
foreign
these blocks are then woven together to
form an island
which can last over 20 years
[Music]
each of these pedora islands is home to
three to ten families
who honor the memory of the uros through
this practice
at the southernmost part of Latin
America is Argentina
where dry and arid desert dominates the
Northwestern landscape
in the province of salta which borders
Bolivia to the North Begins a Mountain
Road that Trails the banks of the
kolansoli river
[Music]
nearing the end of its almost 12 mile
run one can see the Church of San Roque
innuestra Senora Del Rosario in iruya a
small town at the edge of the mountain
that sits at over 9000 feet above sea
level
[Music]
the celebration of the Virgen De Rosario
is an example of the religious
syncretism that defines iruya
while the pre-columbian culture prevails
an agricultural traditions of the region
the popular festivities provide an
example of the cultural blend that
occurred during the Spanish Conquest
although Catholic Worship Is predominant
the clothing and ceremonial dances are
proof of their indigenous roots
the celebration marks the beginning of
the planting season
and the main celebration is the
procession that takes place on the first
Sunday of October
this veneration to the Virgin was
brought by the Spanish
[Music]
the indigenous populations worship
pachamama
or Mother Earth
[Music]
the only way to reach iruya is through
the umaguaka Ravine located in the
neighboring province of huhui
foreign
on both sides of the Rio Grande the
different types of clay display a
colorful landscape on the mountain range
this Valley is full of multi-colored
Hills like the ones in ornocal
better known as the hill of 14 colors
[Music]
the mountain range dates back 75 million
years when the last dinosaurs lived
and its highest point sits at 15 600
feet above sea level
[Music]
almost 200 miles Southwest from ornokar
is a vast extension of white land known
as the salar of arizarro
[Music]
Salt Flat in the world
at its southern end a small volcano with
a weak eruption formed a perfect natural
pyramid
the cone of arita
a true geological mystery
salt and black lava combined to erect
the sharp cone that stands
482 feet tall
approximately the size of the Great
Pyramid of kiops in Egypt
scientists claim it was shaped by the
intense Winds of the area
salt and wind are the two primary
elements of this region of Argentina
about two hours by car near the
municipality of dolar Grande
there are a series of seawater Springs
known as Ojos de Mar
the microorganisms found here date back
to the very origins of Earth
[Music]
foreign
like stromatolites that endure
environments with extreme conditions
similar to what was Earth 3.5 billion
years ago
[Music]
remains almost invisible to the human
eye but it has existed for thousands of
years
the Argentine Patagonia
at the southernmost end of Latin America
covers nearly one-third of the
Continental surface of Argentina
with luscious mountains and valleys
[Music]
every year from June to December the
Valdez Peninsula is home to hundreds of
Southern right whales
that migrate here to mate give birth and
nurse their young
this natural reserve is located halfway
between Buenos Aires and the Garibaldi
pass in Tierra del Fuego
the southern right whale can be
distinguished by its lack of a dorsal
fin
and by their unique v-shaped blow which
can reach a height of up to 13 feet
[Music]
the whole region is Bountiful
south of Valdez Peninsula Punta Tombo
has the largest Continental Colony a
magellanic penguins in the world
around 800 000 specimens migrate here
from September to April to give birth
the males arrive first to secure a space
for nesting
females arrive a month later
after giving birth the Penguins returned
to Sea where they remain for the other
half of the year
foreign
two hours away by car is Union Beach a
long stretch of white sand that comes
alive in summer
one of its main attractions is a marine
mammal that is endemic to Southern
Argentina
the commerson's dolphin
a citation of barely five feet that
stands out for its great swimming skills
[Music]
the congressman's dolphin usually swims
near the coast
in waters under 328 feet deep
it is a social being that seems
comfortable around humans
[Music]
at the foothills of the Andes on the
opposite side of the country
is Los glacieres National Park
which hosts 1 000 square miles of desert
covered by Ice
twice the size of the city of Los
Angeles
it is the largest national system of
protected areas in the country
and the third largest source of fresh
water on the planet
if global warming continues at the
current trend
60 of the ice in this park
could be gone by the year 2100.
[Music]
the most famous of these glaciers is
perito Moreno a glacier in constant
movement
[Music]
every year the 3.1 miles of its frontal
wall grows 2 300 feet towards the
peninsula
until the water pressure cracks the
structure
creating spectacular ruptures
[Music]
in the southernmost end of Argentina is
Tierra del Fuego
an island separated from the mainland by
the Magellan Street
its capital ushwaya city
is the longest days and nights of the
year in Argentina
[Music]
this city of over 80 000 residents
started growing when a Penitentiary
known as prison at the End of the World
opened in 1920.
it was the inmates themselves that built
the prison and started populating this
remote region
[Music]
our journey through the vast territory
of Latin America and its natural wonders
ends here
a land rich with diverse cultures
with people who are proud of their roots
firmly towards the future
[Music]
thank you